les chéris également vous le savez on
aime les gens qui nous regardent
on aime les gens qui sont autour de la
table et on aime également le public
oui et ce soir il y a des gros gros
cadeau je vous le dis hier c'était la
fête des mères d y embrasse toutes les
mamans sont toujours vivants c'est à
dire que si vous avez offert à abong
mbang tient pour ceux qui ont offert des
fruits des fleurs des fleurs voilà des
fleurs et c'est le geste qui compte
voilà c'est le geste qui compte benhaim
un sac un sac ou pas mal un sac
plastique
oui c'est ça je veux dire c'est la fête
des mères et chercher plein de trucs qui
à ma mère et du coup je vous le dis il
me reste quelques trucs est ce que dans
le public en a qui veulent des cadeaux
le public jouira tanger rien ce qui me
reste en stock
non merci mais henry non ça c'est beau
ça mais c'est ce que j'ai dit pitbull ou
[Applaudissements]
regardez
pour fumer regardez là c'est moi
s'il te plaît tu me casses les articles
chez nikos me citer pèle sur tf1 la la
chanson l'admin il y met pas d'accord
donc là je t'explique donc regarder ce
qu'on a
vous pas tous dans le public les chérit
les interchangeables regardez alors
c'est une marque de ouf a orné de
cristaux swarovski swarovski le joueur
de foot en tonnes soit rose qui lui les
psig l'epsic de liepzig et longa et je
rajoute pour tout le monde
présent dans public forcément ceux qui
sont absents du public ils ne l'ont pas
à soi et massages bien-être pour deux
personnes
[Applaudissements]
op
ah ah
on vous distribue tout ça dans un but
des chats pour l'instant les shérifs
m'aider doit aller voir si on peut les
vendre plus cher mais c'est sa tombe
j'attends j'attends golaz voilà tout cas
mon chéri tiens joseph tiens je te loft
time of en ce moment tu as une enfant
tue l'offrira de ma part mais parce que
je la connais bien
[Applaudissements]